je suis une manette femmes je ne veux
pas reçu d'argent de mireille métellus
bonjour qui juillet bonjour moins bien
c'est bien bravo
metellus 40 ans de carrière c'est quoi
20 films dans le série télé 30 pièces de
théâtre c'était une superbe carrière qui
s'étale est en fait une des doyennes
parmi les comédiennes noirs du québec
vous êtes né à port-au-prince je signe à
port au prince le cargo québec et
comment vous avez décidé de devenir
comédienne comme comédienne vraiment ça
a commencé avec des activités plus
d'amateurs
quand j'étais sur scène je ne sentais je
disais un poème ça me faisait comme
j'étais prête
même si je n'avais pas fait les écoles
de toute façon cette époque vous savez
peut-être que vous ne savez pas bhl
c'était pas évident pour une jeune noire
de dire de jouer et rentrer dans une
école de théâtre de toutes façons à 7
dans les années 60 début 70
c'est dommage à dire mais j'ai déjà eu
la phrase qui m'a dit d'écouter ya pas
de travail pour le québécois blancs
alors pensez vous que vous allez en
avoir vous mais j'ai toujours insisté
bien sûr j'ai fait mes études en tant
qu'enseignante je suis tombé d'accord
guettait revenant psychosocial j'ai fait
des diplômes ce niveau mais toujours et
grâce aux blacks il ressort que j'ai pu
rencontrer des gens et j'ai pu vraiment
apprendre sur le tas est ce que je
pourrais avoir la clé pour aller chez
vous madame d est un homme votre premier
grand rôle à la télévision et corrigez
moi chez tard c'était dans les héritiers
duval et oui quels souvenirs gardez-vous
de cette série là à mon dieu c'est
justement de me donner la possibilité
justement de faire des jeux pensés dans
les héritiers duval que j'ai fait
que jésus est loin des ruines oman
l'ajustement jeunes drogués ça ça n'a
pas fait plaisir à la communauté a
certainement dit à m je me rappelle même
il y avait une lettre aux lecteurs là
dans le dans la presse quand le fait que
j'avais joué le rôle d'une ironie normal
et juste avant je faisais une
cardiologue danse ou un ciel variable
voilà et au théâtre et la même chose ça
vous avez raison il s'agit d'un
infarctus à nos parents inférieur les
signes vitaux sont stabilisés le chacal
est passé de 4000 à sion dont populaire
et après ça ça ça a décollé parce que
une lance et compte youtube de choses
aussi des parfois des rôles un peu
secondaire
oui des fois tu veux dire comme on dit
il n'ya pas de petit run comme distincts
minsk il ya que deux petits acteurs
mais quand je jouais souvent je dis même
à la jeune génération
je le redis je n'ai pas fait je ne fais
pas la télé je ne participe à une piste
du diable pour qu'on puisse que je sois
connu que je sois a reconnu mais bien
pour le plaisir de le faire
tout d'abord bien sûr ça fait plaisir au
public il nous faut un public n'est ce
pas mais de penser à soi d'abord de
penser à toi voilà tout ce que le bon
dieu a voulu donner au noir c'est des
rêves mais nous a donné nos enfants pour
que nous rêve se réalise un de vous
rendre et saint-marc ans était dans la
pièce d'héritage en montérégie cetam
qu'est ce qui est écrit il ya plusieurs
décennies les 60 ans resteront très
marquante mais j'ai un peu l'impression
aussi que c'est une pièce marquante pour
le théâtre d'ici tout à fait virage où
on met en scène les comédiens vont des
comédiens noirs
gellé vécu vraiment très de façon très
profonde très c'était riche c'était
émouvant s'étaient tous sens et puis de
travail avec un jeune un jeune metteur
en scène c'était main c'était quelque
chose à vous ont dirigé des motions là
non ça ouais ouais important pour le
québec c'est un signal mais en même
temps oui c'est de voir cette ouverture
là et en même temps de voir pour le
grand public
parce que c'est pas on ne plaisantait
pas pour un public moi c'est que tout le
monde l'est effectivement les noirs sont
venus parce qu'ils ont beaucoup ils ont
rempli la salle de la salle de 17
parce que justement il se ils se sont
fait représenter
tu vis dans un autre monde mon gars dans
mon temps on avait peur de se faire mais
je suis tout ce qu'on voulait c'est
d'être là il ya beaucoup de chemin
parcouru ces dernières années maintenant
comment vous voyez la suite le toute
façon la lutte continue à la lutte
continue il faut que c'est une lutte
il faut continuer la suite quand je dis
tout ce n'est pas une question de tous
les noirs seulement c'est pour tout le
monde
pour les autochtones qui sont ici qui
doit se battre d'être prison d'être
présenté c'est une lutte continuelle
scom là c'est comme les droits des
femmes c'est pas parce qu'on a gagné
telle chose qu'il faut arrêter il faut
continuer parce que la jeune génération
ne sais pas ce qu'ils ont lutté gspr moi
j'ai fait des grèves 1 j'ai participé à
des grèves pour qu'on est con qu'on
obtienne quelque chose qu'on a
aujourd'hui quand tout est tout à fait
normal mais sa pire rester groupe train
brusquement comme ça on peut couper puis
bang
il faut recommencer donc c'est une hutte
faudrait voir l'oeil ouvert il fait des
hâtifs à l'arrimer tonus merci merci
avant vraiment c'est un honneur pour moi
merci
[Musique]